en este vídeo vamos a pensar un poco en
las líneas paralelas y otras líneas que
cortan a las líneas paralelas que las
intersectan son llamadas líneas
transversales entonces primero pensemos
en lo que son las líneas paralelas una
definición que podríamos usar la cual yo
pienso que va a funcionar de maravilla
para el propósito de este vídeo entonces
bueno voy a dibujar aquí voy a dibujar
dos líneas ajá dos líneas sobre un mismo
plano y cuando yo me refiero a un plano
me refiero a bueno tú puedes imaginar
una superficie plana de dos dimensiones
tal como la pantalla cierto la pantalla
tiene dos dimensiones entonces podría
funcionar como plano así que dibuja una
línea una línea está sobre este plano y
otra línea estas van en la misma
dirección son paralelas jamás se cortan
y son sobre el mismo plano y bueno
siguen y siguen indefinidamente estas
líneas son paralelas jamás en la vida se
van a cortar entonces si tú piensas en
qué tipo de líneas no son paralelas
bueno muy bien aquí esta línea verde
esta línea rosa estas líneas no son
paralelas claramente se intersectan en
ese punto
ahora bien algunas veces te pueden
especificar poniendo una flechita
indicando que van en la misma dirección
sólo para mostrar que esas dos líneas
son paralelas así que esto dice que son
líneas paralelas o simplemente tú puedes
poner la condición decir estas líneas
jamás se van a interpretar y listo ahora
lo que queremos pensar es qué pasa
cuando estas dos líneas son
interceptadas por una tercera línea eso
es interesante cierto así que voy a
dibujar aquí una tercera línea ahí está
la tercera línea esta línea que
intersecta las dos paralelas es llamada
una línea transversal esto se le llama
una línea transversal y bueno cada que
te encuentres con en tu tarea o en un
examen o un problema de geometría
cualquiera con una transferencia se
corta a dos líneas paralelas tendrás una
relación interesante muy muy interesante
para los ángulos y los ángulos que se
forman a igual eso ahorita lo vamos a
ver bueno de hecho es una es un caso muy
común que te encuentres con esto con dos
paralelas
bersal que las cortas y lo primero que
debes hacer es darte cuenta darte cuenta
que si estas dos líneas son paralelas
vamos a asumir que son paralelas
entonces tendremos que ángulos
correspondientes tienen la misma medida
a qué me refiero con ángulos
correspondientes bueno tú aquí puedes
ver aquí puedes ver que que se forman
cuatro ángulos entonces por la
transversal a transversal corta cada una
de las líneas y se forman cuatro ángulos
aquí está uno de ellos ahora en naranja
aquí está otro ángulo ajá y acá está
otro ángulo en color verde y finalmente
finalmente tenemos aquí otro ángulo y
esos son los cuatro ángulos los cuatro
ángulos que se forman entonces cuando
hablamos de ángulos correspondientes
simplemente nos referimos por ejemplo a
este ángulo este ángulo de aquí este
alguno corresponde a este ángulo de
abajo ajá entonces lo voy a poner aquí
en verde también para para indicar que
miden lo mismo exacto esos son ángulos
correspondientes ángulos
correspondientes miden lo mismo
este ángulo mide digamos no sean 70 70
grados entonces este mide 70 grados
también este mide 70 grados no es
increíble eso está está perfecto ok
entonces bueno supongamos ve a la cocina
y hagan unos palillos y hace este dibujo
y cambia la transversal tú vas a ver ahí
ahí podrás ver qué miden lo mismo los
ángulos correspondientes ahora si yo
tengo voy a dibujar aquí otras dos
líneas paralelas pondré otro ejemplo un
poco más un poco más extremo para que te
asustes un poco así que aquí están las
dos líneas paralelas y ahora una
transversal nos hace falta a transversal
va aquí así y se forman ángulo cierto
aquí este es congruente a este otro
ángulo y ahora lo mismo pasa con este
otro ejemplo el primero que hicimos
estos dos ángulos este ángulo y este
ángulo son ángulos correspondientes
ahora bien este otro ángulo izquierdo
superior izquierdo mide lo mismo que
este ángulo también superior izquierdo
y ahora este otro el color verde este
mide lo mismo supongamos y mide no sé de
70 también este mide 70 grados y
finalmente finalmente tenemos también
que el ángulo morado este ángulo mide lo
mismo que este ángulo todos son ángulos
correspondientes miren lo mismo así que
lo voy a escribir aquí para que quede
bien claro entonces ángulos
los correspondientes ángulos
correspondientes miden lo mismo son
congruentes miden lo mismo son iguales y
eso pasa para cada par de ángulos en el
mismo color ahora viene el siguiente
conjunto de ángulos congruentes son a
veces llamados ángulos verticales o
ángulos opuestos también se les puede
llamar pero si se toma este ángulo este
ángulo que es vertical opuesto al que
está justo cruzando la cruzando el punto
de intersección este ángulo éste también
mide 70 grados ajá entonces me dé lo
mismo mide lo mismo que el opuesto a él
podemos decir que son ángulos opuestos y
de hecho me gusta la palabra opuestos
porque no siempre está en la dirección
vertical a veces puede ser la dirección
horizontal o se puede se pueden referir
a ellos como ángulos verticales ángulos
opuestos o verticales son también
ángulos iguales si este ángulo mide 70
también este mide 70 grados es
interesante porque si este ángulo mide
70 también éste mide 70 así que no
importa cuánto mira cuánto mira uno el
opuesto a él mide lo mismo
lo mismo no importa que no importa todos
en todos esos ángulos en color amarillo
mide lo mismo 70 grados ahora bien a
continuación vamos a ver
continuando con esto el siguiente lo
siguiente importante que tenemos que ver
aquí es la relación que tienen estos dos
ángulos el verde y el naranja tu puedes
ver puedes ver que cuando sumas dos
ángulos ha recorrido la mitad de un
círculo cierto ahora si inicias inicias
aquí y con el ángulo verde luego pasco
en el ángulo naranja entonces recorre la
mitad de un círculo esto te dará 180
grados en total entonces este ángulo
verde y este ángulo naranja deben sumar
un total de 180 grados son ángulos
suplementarios ya lo vimos en otro vídeo
ahora bien sólo date cuenta que están
sobre la misma línea o sobre la mitad de
un círculo así que este mide 70 grados
entonces este otro ángulo cuánto mide
mide 110 grados cierto este mide 110
grados 110 + 70 grados son 180 grados
así que bien entonces cuánto mide este
ángulo este ángulo acá el opuesto cuánto
mide también mide ciento
grado cierto porque son ángulos opuestos
opuestos por un vértice y también
sabemos que este ángulo corresponde a
este ángulo así que también mide 110
grados o podríamos pensarlo como bueno
este mide 70 grados y como el naranja es
un ángulo suplementario al ángulo de 70
grados ambos deben sumar 180 así que
también bueno como éste mide 110 grados
este es el ángulo correspondiente
también mide 110 grados o podemos pensar
bueno este es opuesto a este o hay
muchas maneras de pensar en esto
simplemente bueno también estos dos son
suplementarios 70 + 110.000 en 180 hay
varias maneras de saber cuánto mide cada
ángulo estos también son suplementarios
70 + 110 miden 180 y en el próximo vídeo
voy a voy a tomar ese tema and veremos
un montón de ejemplos para saber que si
sabes la medida de un ángulo podrá saber
el resto de las medidas